[Music]
good afternoon everybody my name is
Brian Kemmler I'm a product manager and
I work on Android accessibility hi and
I'm Ricardo Garcia a solar engineer in
the audio framework team in Android
how's everybody's last day of i/o last
last session you made it through thank
you so much for coming out it was a
great IO on today we have a lot of
really exciting things to talk about
primarily geared for developers we're
gonna be talking about a new sound
enhancement feature in Android P called
sound amplifier we're gonna be doing a
little bit of a live demo to show how we
can improve the sound in any type of
situation for users and how you can do
the same as a developer we're gonna go
and do a deep dive into the inner
workings of sound amplifier and the
dynamics processing effect upon which
it's built live with code examples it's
gonna be really cool let's dive right in
listening is difficult even in a empty
field with a massive set of ears but the
everyday reality is we live work and
play with an increasing amount of
environmental noise in fact unwanted
sound is one of the most common
environmental problems it's not only
annoying but it prevents us from
understanding our friends colleagues and
loved ones no matter how well we can
hear most of us can relate to the
following acoustically challenging
situations trying to understand your
date in a loud restaurant or a loud bar
trying to listen to a caller in a really
loud airport lounge trying to listen to
a speaker who's talking way too softly
like me now one could think of
environmental noise as a form of
situational disability but what if you
could hear better using just your
smartphone so you never miss a word in
the conversation now you can because
today we're introducing sound amplifier
what is sound amplifier sound amplifier
is a new accessibility service that
helps users focus on real-world
conversations using only your Android
smartphone and a set of headphones users
can tune to hundreds of personalized
levels to optimize their listing
experience to the current environment
its two sliders for loudness and tuning
dynamically adjust over 100 audio
presets in the background these settings
can be applied independently to each ear
adjusting them improves the sound
quality in an array of situations
including the following enhancing sound
in loud distant or otherwise
acoustically challenging situations
increasing the volume of somebody who
speaks talked saw to softly
turning up the TV volume to one that's
acceptable to everybody in the room
without blasting everybody else so now
I'm gonna go in and talk a little bit
about how we built it the api's and the
effect upon which it was built and I'll
do some demos sound amplifier is based
on Android peas new dynamics processing
effect the effect is a four stage signal
processing architecture and I'm gonna
walk you through each stage and then
Ricardo's going to come in a little bit
and really deep dive in into this and
show the developers in the audience
exactly how they can adapt this to their
applications so first
stage one stage one is pre equalization
you can think of pre equalization as an
equalizer that you can programmatically
adjust any audio frequency think bass
mid-range treble the entire audio
spectrum Stage two is a multiband
compressor the multiband compressor is
the heart and soul of the dynamics
processing effect because what it does
is really unique it can simultaneously
adjust down really loud or irritating
sounds don't worry I won't make any or
and just adjust up sounds that are too
soft it could do all of this without
changing the characteristics of the
underlying audio that you put into the
system the third stage is also an
equalization stages post equalization
allows you to fine-tune the output from
the original MBC and the original pre
equalizer and lastly is the limiter what
the limiter does is protects a dish
protects users from additional gain or
additional volume above a certain
developer designated threshold so that
there are no loud jarring or
uncomfortable note noses so now I'm
gonna switch switch over into it do a
little demo so I'm gonna play a very
typical google micro kitchen water
cooler type of type of break where
there's a loud espresso maker in the
background and I'm in this I star in
this
so you can hear the sound is it you
can't really hear the conversation I
swam far enough to escape do you really
fun too so I can dynamically adjust this
and start to hear the conversation
remember this is customizable or tunable
for every user doing this again again I
get to start again I'm really not this
into myself
here's me talking kind of rehearsing
this talk right now and I'm speaking too
quietly so this will be another example
of how I can adjust the sound so that I
can hear it better the other thing that
I also forgot to mention was you use
this with your headphones so you can
think of what's in the video as you know
what you would be hearing in your
headphones so this thing is difficult
even though they're the best
circumstances in a quiet field no
background noise and a large set of ears
so you can hear the boost but in noisy
conditions the everyday reality is that
we work play and live with an increasing
amount of environmental noise so
listening is difficult so it's very easy
to fine tune any acoustic situation to
the environment to your to your ears and
so forth and Ricardo is gonna deep dive
in and talk a little bit about a little
bit more about the dynamics processing
effect and how developers can start
using this today Oh No thank you
well now we saw the demos and we saw a
sound amplifier actually working real
life so we are going to go down and see
how the sound fire actually works and
what is the magic behind it so for that
I want you to introduce to introduce to
you the hearing treasure I'm going to be
in this aside for a second I'm going to
explain to you what is here in here we
are seeing what is they are
soon treasure for the average human the
human ratio is actually how much energy
we need to have to be able to listen to
the sound
so in this plot we can see from left to
right from low frequency to high
frequencies from 20 Hertz to 20
kilohertz and in the vertical axis we
can see the amplitude we see how much
energy we actually will need to hear the
sounds so because this is the thracian
of hearing in quiet these very much
telling that anything that is below that
ratio will not be heard by people so for
example if we go and we look into the
4000 Hertz we see that the threshold is
lower in there then means that we need
less energy we need a lot let the sounds
can be fainter they can be softer and we
will hear them where you have a sound
that is about the same level in around I
don't know hundred Hertz you will not be
able to hear that so this is important
because many companies use this curves
this kind of tree is a human treasure
curves to design their equipment when
you are designing I don't know
mp3 or CD players it discuss our present
or if you are tuning a headset speakers
microphones all of these curves are
really important to know what people
will actually hear and what they are
sensitive to but this course can shift
so we can have healing threshold shifts
due to so many circumstances let's say
the noise in the environment a minute
ago we have the AC blasting here and
that was a threshold shift we needed to
have sounds that were weighed louder
over that ratio to be able to listen to
hear the sounds when they see it turn
off a minute ago as well we can speak
softer and we can we hear that our
threshold shifted down at the moment so
a threshold shift is a region that will
need more energy for you to be able to
notice that we have other ships we can
have shifts that are not as broadband
not all over the spectrum and the
previous one we can have shifts there
are more localized this blue curve in
here is showing us our shift that is
around 500 Hertz
really
really really high there is some noise
or some obstruction there that is not
going to allow you to hear things very
well around 500 Hertz these shifts could
be permanent or all your lives are going
to have that shift or could be temporary
as Brian mentioned could be a temporary
situational disability that means that
for that period of time for you are not
going to be able to hear things around
those frequencies because either your
headphones are not working well you are
enough noise the environment your ears
are not working well at that moment
sounds that are below that threshold
that shifted threshold you are not going
to be able to hear that and that's the
important takeaway from this if he's
below the threshold you cannot hear so
what happens when we have a sound of
interest let's say that you are
listening to music or someone is
speaking or some sound that interests
you so in depth in the plot I just put a
blob that's a green blob in there and
it's a broadband sound has a lot of
frequencies and it has energy all over
the place but if you notice again around
500 Hertz a lot of the energy that is
below the threshold the shifted tray so
the blue one is going to be lost when
you have a sound of interest that is
below the treasure the shifted ratio a
is it's going to be difficult to be
heard or the intially dental ability is
really bad you cannot understand the
sound so this is the question that
everybody is asking how can sound
amplifier help us right now so I'm glad
that you asked
sound employer is going to take the
sounds and is going to actually boost
them word you need them the most
if we look again in the in the range
from 500 Hertz to 1 kilohertz
we took the sounds and in this new
process sound we took the sounds that
were really soft that they didn't have
that much energy and we boosted them all
the way over the chip the treasure so
now we can hear those but very important
we took the sounds that were already
loud and we moved them up but not too
much up so the loud sounds got louder
but not too loud so if you see this the
process that happened it was not uniform
all over the spectrum it was shifting
and trying to accommodate them over our
shifted treasurer so he was doing a very
intelligent boost in there all of this
processing is done by the new dynamics
processing effect that we introduced in
hundred in and repeat and I'm going to
talk more I'm going to show call in a
minute I promise so the dynamics
processing effect as Brian mentioned is
the new process in fact that we have it
has four stages the pre queue multiband
compressor pasa queue and limiter and
when we are using this effect we have
two big questions that we need to answer
especially for our Sun amplifier first
is what kind of processing we actually
want to hear sounds to be able to
depending of the needs that we have if
we ran loud environment or we are in a
bad connection or we are in an airport
or depending what kind of processing we
need to make things above they shifted
trash of that we have and the second is
how users can actually go and move and
find the right parameters that they need
for you so we have two big questions to
answer the first one for the processing
what kind of processing we want a we did
what Google is really good at we took a
lot of data and we start crunching that
data
so we took data from a hearing treasures
from regular and impaired hearing
impaired users so actually how people
hear how their ears respond and we put
them in there
we took threshold ships from different
environment places and different
Berryman noises we went to airport
restaurants and places where we have
noise obstructions things that are going
to shift our threshold of hearing and we
also put them in in the blender and a we
went to a and try to get the audio
content from the the audio content
people actually want to hear a
conversations movies music a live
concerts a lectures and we managed to
pull all of this together and come up
with a set of eight recipes of
parameters that would be good for
processing the sound in many situations
when you do that you end up with I will
a multi-dimensional space a bunch of
solutions that are pretty much
parameters very complex parameters that
you want to tell the dynamics effects
processor Oh for this situation this
will be good to shift the sound for this
situation will be that but that's
unmanageable if you want to tell the
users will start moving parameters like
this will be hundreds of parameters and
it will be very difficult for the users
to make something good with this so we
took a further step and did some
dimensionality reduction took all of
those recipes multi-dimensional space
and flatten them out and plotted them in
two dimensions in here in the plus in
the right you can see that we see each
one of those is kind of a formula or a
processing a recipe that we want to feed
the dynamics processing effect to change
the sound and with the dimensionality
reduction we found two major axes the
tone and the boost the users so this
solves the second question that we have
how the users are going to navigate this
well they don't need to know the all the
parameters that we need we just give
them two sliders the two sliders that
would you saw on the demo and by moving
the sliders they are actually doing a
very intelligent mapping and going and
moving at thousandth parameter well
notice and hundreds of parameters that
are moving for each channel in there
when the user goes and iterate using the
sliders they are actually going to a
bunch of a recipes a bunch of a
Processing's and they can find the one
that Suites them the best at that moment
for that user in that location and
that's what we wanted to do so that was
kind of like a bird eye view or how the
Sun amplifier works now we are going to
go deeper and start talking about code
what can you do with the dynamics
effects a processing effect so you can
find the diamond processing effect in as
a new library in the Android media audio
effects dynamics processing and right
now so let's start talking about use
cases so when can you use a dynamics
processing effect the first use case we
saw a length you can do a Sun amplifier
so if you go today because this is now
available in the Android
a pea Developer Preview you can go
tonight I'm sure that everybody is going
to skip the party and go and create your
own dynamics do your own Sun amplify so
with a sound amplifier with the damage
process effect we are expecting people
to create their own Sun amplifiers or
create their own solutions to be able to
hear better to listen better another
example another activity that can happen
is a when do you have a device an
Android device and you want to tune the
speakers or the headphones
many companies a have sold one that will
equalize or do something to the
headphones to make them son a flatter
better to have more bass something you
want now
with this effect it would be easy for
you and for clients to do that another
application that is really interesting
is that TV midnight mode if you are
watching TV
2:00 a.m. you cannot sleep but if you
start watching a movie and sometimes
someone is whispering the movie just
saying something really quiet and
immediately bump music comes in there al
something really loud you walk up
everybody in the house with a dynamics
processing head you can actually have
something that they whisper the very
soft parts of the movie can be raised up
but the very loud music or gunshots or
whatever is happening in the movie it
can bring down and everything is going
to a more level variable sound in there
more level sound another example can be
for media players you are doing your own
media player and you want to actually do
some loudness maximization or master you
want you want to listen to classical
music in your media player and you and
you are in a train you would like to
have the control to be able to again
squeeze the loud sounds and bring up the
soft sounds so everything is working
well for the dynamic range that you have
in there now I'm going to talk a little
bit about architecture and I promise
cold is coming but I want to show that
protection we are giving you a lot of
power with this effect so we the
architecture that we show before we were
kind of lying is not as simple it's a
little bit more complex the architecture
yes we have four stages we have a pretty
Q multiband compressor pasa Q and
limiter but we can do more things in
there inside of each one of
stages we have a lot of parameters that
you can control
we have demands and in the pre queue
multiband compression and posse queue we
can have as many bands as you want and
you can control each one of those bands
and the parameters in those bands the
limiter is a single band limited but you
can also control that all of these is it
comes into a channel so a channel what
we have defined in the channel as let's
say you have a stereo signal stereo
signal has two channels left and right
so we are going to have channel 0 and
channel 1 and you can control all those
independently all you can have many more
channels let's say that you have a 5.1 a
signal you actually have six channels
that you can control and you can index
all of those channels and say I want to
change the multi one parameter the
multiband controller band number three
in the channel two and I want to change
this we are giving you an API to do all
of those things one thing that I want
you to notice is the limiters the
limiters are linked limiters I'm going
to talk more about that but it's
important when you are talking about
buta channel to be able to change all
the limiters kind of at once if you need
so now finally code yes we promise code
we have some code so this is an instance
instance here is an example of the
dynamics processing effect for this we
decide because we have so many
parameters and so many things that can
be configured to have a conflict builder
so you create a config builder and then
we are actually going to instantiate the
effect first with a config builder in
this example we we can have some
parameters like the variant the number
of channels I have to talk more about
this dozen a second then we can enable
or disable each one of the stages in
this example we have all the stages
enabled yes we want to use pre queue
multiband compressor post EQ and limiter
and the number of bands we can say how
many bands we want per stage type so in
I can have all the pre cues can have
let's say eight bands the multiband
compressor ten bands and the post-acute
13 bands the only limitation is like the
stage type needs to have the same number
of bands but then you can choose any
number of bands that you
we have some extra parameters as I
mentioned they variant and the number of
channels and the self-refer frame
duration that you you can set in the
config builder then in the last line we
are actually creating a configuration we
are saying build and we have a
configuration object then I I don't want
to use the configuration directly
sometimes I want to finish their key
texture of my effect and go and change
the default parameters so in this
example I'm getting a channel I'm
getting a channel object in the first
line from the config and I'm saying from
channel number zero in this case get the
multiband compressor we have the
multiband compressor stage and then i
iterate through the 8a multi-bank bands
that I have in my bull t1 compressor and
I went and changed the parameters in
each one of them this is an example for
IO
I'm sure and in real world applications
you can go and do more things but you
see that we can go and set each one of
the things that we want the release the
attack the ratio the ratio the way that
you want for each one of the bands and
finally we go an instance yet the the
dynamics processing effect my diocesan
effect and you can instantiate it with a
config file that we just created and the
session ID that's way to attach this
effect to whatever the media player or
the audio track that of interest for you
and then you can start just going in
your program and controlling everything
I'm going to instead of going on the API
and just showing like the dry cold I'm
going to go a little bit more meta more
conceptual to show this in graphics a
little bit so in the configuration or
when we are running real-time we can
have access to channels that I just show
you and we have many channels so the
channel option and we can index the
channel by index number so 0 1 2 3 we
can get the external each channel object
actually has some parameters like the
input game that you can go and change on
the channel or you have stages you can
access the pre eq multiband compressor
pasa Q or limiter
and a let's say and this moment in the
EQ you can actually graph take you body
cues look exactly the same from the API
level from the API viewpoint and you can
go and change the parameters on the EQ
or change the parameters in each one of
the Bands there sorry it's going very
deeper so we can go from we can go from
band to a the EQ from channel and then
the collection of channels so we have
access to all the granularity that we
want there the same thing for the
multiband compressor we can access the
multiband compression inside of the
channel and then access the parameters
that we have in each one of the bands
and lastly the limiter we don't have
bands in the limiter only parameters
there and we can access that so now I'm
going to dive a little bit more on each
stage type and what are they they access
or that we have the setters and getters
that we have their first the equaliser I
think that most people are familiar with
the equaliser but what what an equaliser
does but if not very quickly when an
equaliser we are going to specify
different frequency bands we are going
to have bands from 0 to 500 Hertz five
hundred to three thousand three thousand
to seven thousand and we are going to
change the energy the level or the gain
that we have in each one of those bands
in here we can set the bands any way
that we want so we can have many bands
and we can have cutoff frequencies any
correct frequency that we want in this
graph is kind of misleading because all
of the ones are the same a width does
not true you can do any weights that you
want and once that you set up the bands
you can go and with the excesses that we
have here we can get the game what is
the current gain or we can set the game
and we can change all of this also real
time we are going to then the multiband
compressor so first disclaimer someone
was pointing out you are only showing
one band in the multiband compressor and
yes i'm showing one band but a this is
this is easy to show what the multiband
compressor does as Brian mentioned and
we have mentioned when you have a
compressor a multiband compressor the
main goal is to take sounds that are
really loud and make them softer and
sounds that are very soft
making louder the way that we have here
represented we have the same sentence in
there before we have out the sentence
that is loud medium and soft in the top
and after we apply the processing of the
multiband compressor is going to look
like they after that is the loud sound
is a little bit softer the medium one
stays medium and the salt one goes very
low the way that a multiband compressor
works or the parameters work a bear with
me for a second for this graphic is we
have the input how what is the level of
the of the signal in the in the
horizontal axis and the numbers are from
minus 100 to 10 they lower the number
like minus 50 is way softer than minus
10 for example some I understand will be
louder a louder sound and when the
compressor what is doing is is analyzing
the input and if the input is above the
threshold we have a threshold parameter
is going to decide to say you know
that's too loud I'm going to bring you
down but if it happens to be below the
treasure is not touch so for example in
this graphic if we choose minus 40 the
input was minus 40 level they all will
be exactly - sorry we are below the
threshold we are not going to modify
that signal but the threshold here is
around 25 minus 25 so if I choose a
value of minus 20 the actual output will
be a around sorry let's say let's choose
an input of minus 10 sorry that's better
minus 10 as an input would map to a
minus 20 to the output then we that the
sound became softer just because it was
above the treasure with all these
parameters with the compression ratio
that ratio and the gain and the gain the
input gain the output gain are the other
parameters we are able to do what we
have been promising that we are able to
take sounds and make them sell out but
take loud sounds and make them softer
and that's what a multiband compressor
is doing and is doing these in different
bands we can take regions of frequency
from 0 to 1000 Hertz and they and be
cave in a different way that the region
from 1,000 to 5,000 will behave we are
giving you all that power to control the
multiband compressor being one of the
most complex ones you can get these
settings and getters so we can get the
attack time release time ratio all these
parameters that you need to actually
configure a compressor and a you do this
per bands I say well there is one thing
and I'm sure that everybody's asking
this why do you have a pregame a
postgame if you move to one compressor
is before and after an equalization and
it's true they are doing they are
redundant they are doing pretty much
exactly the same but we did that for one
reason we talked to a lot of developers
and people that actually have a lot of
these algorithms in real life and some
come from a big portion of them they
really like to have an equalization and
then a multiband compressor to do some
tuning of the microphone certain
speakers some of them won't like to have
a multiband compressor and then an
equalization stage so the easiest ways
for us to make this effect very
Universal was to built in some
redundancy and do the API in such a way
that they can easily port all their
arguments to this the last stage is the
limiter the limiter is pretty much the
same that the multiband compressor but
it's a single man so we don't have
multiple bands and what this is doing is
pretty much the same is taking a sound
and if it's way too loud if it's about
certain level in the threshold is just
going to squash that down it's very
useful and it's usually found at the end
of any audio processing chain especially
to protect the speakers you don't want
that the processing did something funky
and the sound is really loud and you
don't want that loud sound to come out
of the speakers so you go and the
limiter is going to say okay sorry this
is - now I'm not going to clip but I'm
just going to squash it down
so it doesn't destroy the speakers so
the limiter is really good and I promise
to mention something about the link the
limiters are link limiters and we have
the link group
when we have multiple channels let's say
that we have two channels and we want a
one of the channels and they are in the
same group and one of the channels the
left channel something really loud
happening that channel is very very loud
if we squeeze on down only the left
channel the stereo image will shift all
the way to the right because this the
right one did nothing but if they are
linked and for some reason one of the
channels got a loud sound both will come
down simultaneously and the stereo
signal the stereo image it will not move
it will stay in the center state where
they needed to be so being able to
control the linked groups in a stereo
signal or in a multi-channel environment
let's say you want to link the stereo
speakers the strong speakers in a
different group so you can keep your a
spatial image intact and that was
another feature that was asked for us to
do well so some more comments about the
dynamics processing effect first one the
real tank controls all the controls and
the API that I tried to summarize in
here but is very big I really encourage
you to go and read the API documentation
all these controls most of them are real
tank controls you can use them and once
that your effect is running you can go
and change pretty much any parameter
that you want you can change the levels
in here you can change the attack they
release the ratio anything that you want
in any of the channels in any of the
Bands a you can also use pretty much the
same API for instantiation sometimes you
want to create an effect and have it
ready to go immediately as soon as it
starts playing is playing with all the
parameters so it will work like that we
also have some implementations at this
moment we are offering two
implementations a to a variants that we
call a favour frequency and favor time
sometimes for these effects if you have
a frequency domain implementation is
good because you can have very precise
frequency it splits in the bands that
you may need for your Algar and at the
same time we are also giving like the
dessert desired frame size a hint that
you can give to the audio engine to the
effect engine to say well you know I
like frequency and I would like to have
frames
about ten milliseconds 20 milliseconds
for your processing so Alto is not a
guarantee you can tell the engine a I
will like to do that
another important thing with this effect
is is built in into AOSP so all a OSP
hundred p OSP is shipping with this
effect but it's an OEM replaceable
effect so if an OEM really wants to come
without a snappier effect or a snap your
implementation or something a they are
encouraged to do that and if we have om
people in the audience please talk to me
afterwards but yes go ahead and do this
and the only thing is like please do
very cool effects with this and very
good quality effects the other thing is
this effect is available for developers
as an insert effect a you can go and
implement it in your application you
have a media player you have a music
application you just go and use the
Android media all effects dynamic
processing effect and it will be
available for you there in the
implementation so summary today we'll
there are a bunch of things the first
one we introduce the new feature the
sound amplifier then so is the new yorks
s ability feature it uses only the
smartphone and a set of headphones and
helps you improve your listening
experience Brian show you a couple of
very cool demos and and thank you for
the some people a take turn off the AC
at that moment so we could hear things a
little bit better a we learn about the
hearing threshold and the hearing
threshold shifts and how they power the
way that the Sun amplifier works and the
last thing we show the dynamics
processing effect they called how the
stages work and how can you go and
create your own dynamics processing
effect to embed in your own applications
so with that we want to give thanks to a
lot of people that were involved in this
project a Brian's team the Android
accessibility team my team the under
media framework team the research team
at Google the Sun understanding team the
our team in Taipei that they helped
implement the applications that you saw
today and I want to thank you for
staying so late the last day of i/o and
a please
contact us if you have any questions
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]